breakups are never easy especially when
your ex goes on to become a wealthy
petrol state but this is what happened
to sweden which was in a union with
norway for almost a century until
they're split in 1905. but what caused
this dissolution why did sweden and
norway break up so as of the closing
years of the napoleonic wars norway was
a part of the kingdom of denmark whose
ruler frederick vi had just sided with
napoleon now a lot of countries in
europe had done the same previously like
russia who would use swedish closeness
with britain as justification to invade
it and grab finland for its own soon
after this russia decided that it didn't
like napoleon anymore and so it was time
for new allies the swedish king wasn't
doing much because of a heart attack but
his government did sense an opportunity
finland wasn't coming back but by siding
with the coalition against napoleon and
his danish ally sweden could gain norway
something which britain russia and
prussia agreed to and even the danish
king agreed to its loss providing he got
to keep greenland and iceland the people
of norway were not happy with suddenly
being the subject of the swedish king
and so the prince of denmark called
christian because of course he was
declared himself the king of norway in
1814 and proclaimed its independence
against the allies he stood no chance of
succeeding but whilst they were busy
fighting napoleon there was an
opportunity to win political support and
he turned to britain whom he felt would
recognize the plight of the norwegian
people and do the right thing to stop
them from being handed over to a foreign
king but fun fact no tensions rose and
when the swedish came to claim their
prize fighting broke out this lasted for
about two weeks and ended with the
swedish making some concessions in
return for norway joining the union
voluntarily norway would keep its
semi-democratic constitution the king's
powers there would be limited and norway
would maintain separate armed forces
relations between the two states
improved over the next half a century
with the swedish-based kings presenting
a much more conciliatory tone to the
norwegian subjects although by doing
this they angered swedish politicians
who saw norway as the junior partner in
the union and many therefore that norway
would never be placated and would simply
keep asking for more and they weren't
wrong norwegian politicians kept asking
for more autonomy over the course of the
late 19th century the big one was when
in 1891 norwegian elections saw the
liberal party victorious the liberals
were proponents of norwegian
independence but if that couldn't be
achieved then they demanded separate
foreign and trade policy for norway this
was a big no-no since at that point the
union would essentially be dead the
norwegian government made a formal
request for these new powers and the
swedish responded with a well-formulated
logical argument no and if you keep
asking we're going to invade the
liberals backed down and over the next
decade instead opted to focus on norway
they removed any reference to the union
from their flag massively increased the
size of the armed forces and built up
border defenses in case of an invasion
and in retaliation the swedish ended
free trade between the two and imposed
tariffs on products from britain
norway's largest trade partner it was
1905 that marked the death of the union
though when the norwegian government
passed a law establishing itself as
separate diplomatic service the king
vetoed this the government resigned the
king refused to accept their resignation
or appoint a new government and as such
the norwegians argued that he was in
violation of the constitution by leaving
norway without leadership and in
response the norwegian parliament
declared its independence in response
sweden mobilized which led norway to do
the same and both army sat on the border
facing off swedish politicians and
commanders were ready for war and it was
only when the swedish people were
overwhelmingly against military action
that they backed down this support was
largely due to the norwegian referendum
in which 99.9 of voters backed
independence which made it clear to
everyone that sweden could no longer
force norway to stay as such the swedish
people threatened mutiny in the army and
the general strike if norway was invaded
which meant that king oscar ii had no
choice but to acknowledge the end of the
union the norwegian people then voted
for a prince of denmark to become king
of norway and thus after a mere 500
years of being controlled by a foreign
power norway would once again be an
independent state i hope you enjoyed
this episode with a special thanks to my
patrons james bissonette kelly
moneymaker mr wolfe skye chappelle adam
stalter jordan longley rod d martin
gareth turner wyan hockey jerry lamdin
spencer lightfoot corso wolff boogerly
wiggly marvin cassar winston k wood
gustav swan marcus asner captain cydog
aaron the white matthew shipley robert
wetzel alex schwinn maggie paxkowski the
mcwhopper anthony beckett coppertone
spinning through plates charles the
first ben evanson scottish trekkie and
words about books podcast